trivia question to determine the first
pick in this draft Peter King Philip
Rivers won't be back with the charges
next year after 16 years and more than
fifty nine thousand passing yards in his
career only four players have more
passing yards for one team then Philip
Rivers has with the Chargers name three
players who have more than fifty nine
thousand passing yards with one team Tom
Brady Drew Brees
Peyton Manning
I missed with me you missed with Peyton
because he was with the Colts and the
Broncos didn't have enough time with the
Colts to get fifty nine thousand yards
Brett Favre with the Packers and Dan
Marino yeah and with and Dan Marino with
the Miami Dolphins the only team that he
ever played for 1984 dad comes my 99
gosh-darn shoot alright I get the first
pick and look this isn't easy
none of these are easy because there is
no obvious team that's good to me that's
gonna say here Phillip here are the keys
and the 25 to 35 million dollars for
2020 that goes along with it you're our
guy we're not gonna draft anybody we're
not bringing you in to be the backup
you're not in danger of being benched
you're not gonna have to compete for the
job you're our guy I don't know who that
would be but to me the one if any that
stand out would be the Indianapolis
Colts all due respect did you cover
percent and Brian Hoyer but that there's
a difference between them and Phillip
Rivers not that Phillip Rivers is going
to make anyone forget about Andrew Luck
but if you can get a couple of years out
of Phillip Rivers and and thrust the
Colts back to some degree of prominence
I think there's something to be said and
Chris Ballard the GM of the cult's was
very candid after the season ended that
they have to get better look it was a
disappointment for the Colts they went
from 5 & 2 to 7 & 9 I believe and you
know Jacoby percent's had his chance and
it didn't work and that doesn't mean you
get rid of him
favorable contract but maybe Phillip
Rivers for a year is what you need right
now if you're the Colts
I think that's a good one Mike you semi
stole that I was either gonna do that or
the team I'm gonna pick which is the
Carolina Panthers under new coach Matt
don't call me JA rule I think the
biggest thing about the Colts is that
you know it would be a projection for
Philip Rivers and I think he's gonna
want to go to a team that that he's
confident that he's gonna win the
starting job and right now I think the
the Carolina Panthers have major doubts
about whether they're gonna bring Cam
Newton back if they don't I think a
marriage of Joe Brady the young Joe
Brady and Phillip Rivers with a
burgeoning young but but growing
receiving corps and you know the best
all-around running back in football I
think would be a real tonic for Phillip
Rivers right now yeah and and look I
think that and you know this idea that
Cam Newton may not be back with the
Panthers that's one of those things that
people are starting to kind of slowly
waking up to but I don't think Cam
Newton will be back and and maybe it is
Cam Newton gets traded to the Chargers
and Phillip Rivers as a practical matter
gets traded to the Panthers although the
Panthers don't have to give up anything
to get in since he's free and clear on
the open market but that would be a nice
little kind of stopover as they figure
out what's next you have Christian
McCaffrey in his prime that would help
Phillip Rivers the offensive line may
not be what he's looking for but when
you have Christian McCaffrey that helps
take some of the heat off of the passing
game so I like that one all right for me
I love a good story and there would be
no better story and I don't idea I I
don't know that there would be no better
story than this but Phillip Rivers to
the Raiders I would love that so much
for a variety of reasons first of all
Derek Carr was a little presumptuous
building a house next door to Jon Gruden
in Las Vegas as if that's gonna
guarantee Derek Carr a year with the Las
Vegas Raiders he hasn't played well
enough to have that guaranteed
I could see Phillip Rivers be a guy that
Jon Gruden looks at and says hey I can
you know if we can iron out some of
these rough spots we can stick it to the
Chargers we can compete he knows the
division
he knows the personnel I love the idea
of the Raiders picking up Phillip Rivers
if there's no one else out there that
they would regard as an available and
acceptable upgrade to derrick karr but i
think they have to be looking for
someone better than derek carr you know
Mike I'm gonna throw a little upset into
this and I'll take the New England
Patriots next and you know but I think
this will be the New England Patriots
with a little bit of an asterisk and
that is this
so the Patriots picked 23rd overall and
the Patriots I think long term realize
they have to invest in a quarterback and
again because I really don't know what's
gonna happen Andy Dalton and I've been
saying for a month he makes a lot of
sense for the Patriots and he does but I
have no idea of Mike Brett he's got a
year left on his contract well Mike
Brown even trade him I don't know will
he release him I doubt him but Phillip
Rivers - the Patriots make sense if they
accompanied this pick with either
committing to Jared Stidham on the other
side of rivers or with the 23rd pick in
the first round maybe they take a a
Jordan Love type you know the Utah State
quarterback who was up and down in his
college career was getting a lot of no
pun intended love before the Senior Bowl
this year and to me that makes a lot of
sense get an insurance policy for the
next year or two while you develop the
long-term quarterback yeah I like that
one and look I think that that Phillip
Rivers may be a guy who you know maybe
he'd be willing to wait and see and
maybe whether he's willing to her not
that there's a chance he will be
available if and when the Patriots
realized Tom Brady's not going to be
there and if and when the Patriots
realized that other options aren't going
to be viable Phillip Rivers becomes a
band-aid for a year to it the most while
they figure out their post Tom Brady
plan I think that is attractive because
it gives them almost like a safety
school where they have that guy that
they know they can bring in and they can
try to make chicken salad out of the
situation while they figure out what
comes next I don't know that there would
be a land rush for Phillip Rivers
sparked by new English
but but Philip Rivers having his name
called for the home opener at Gillette
Stadium I think the reaction will be a
lot more positive than if it were be it
to be an Andy Dalton or really anyone
else all right I'm gonna go with the
Bears
Peter you mentioned the Bears last hour
I'm kind of stealing your thought on the
Bears I think I don't know that you can
sell rivers on this unless Matt Negi and
Ryan pace say to Philip hey you know
we're gonna give Mitch a chance here but
you know we don't really believe we just
need to go through the motions for a few
weeks of the regular season just to
confirm that having this fire lit under
his butt isn't gonna make a difference I
just don't know the Philip but you know
the more I talk about it I'm kind of
talking myself out of it because I don't
think Philip Rivers is gonna want it but
if he wants to stay in the NFL this may
be his only option there may not be that
team that says you're our guy from day
one here's the money
here's the keys to the offense you don't
have to compete with anyone you don't
have to sit and wait and it may be that
if he really wants to stay in the NFL
that this is what he's gonna have to
accept Mike the reason why that makes so
much sense really is because you know he
could look at himself as sort of an earl
morale you know as sort of a George
Blanda
you know a guy who in his last year or
two goes to a team not that those guys
went to a team they were already there
but a guy who plays for a team that is
kind of superb already and they just
have a problem or an injury at
quarterback that makes the most sense to
me the only problem that I see with
Chicago is that Matt Negi probably other
than Andy Reid and Brett Veatch but this
just I'm guessing there may not be a
person in professional football that
Matt Negi is closer to than chase Daniel
you know he they're they're they're very
close you know on and off the field and
so I just look at this thing and I
basically say essentially that it's
gonna take a real leap for her for Matt
Nagy to go to somebody else other than
chase DNA not saying
do it my third pick is gonna be Tampa
Bay because I think that Bruce Arians
has experience with older veteran
quarterbacks he loves them and Bruce
Arians knows hey listen I've got a year
maybe two left you know doing this job I
want to have the best possible chance
with a very good offense in two great
receivers I want to have a very good
chance to make a Super Bowl and my best
chance better than Jameis Winston is
with Phillip Rivers yeah I don't
disagree with that if they decide they
don't want Jameis Winston that's the
threshold determination that you know
it's not like they've announced he won't
be back like the Chargers have done with
Phillip Rivers so we watch and wait to
see what happens with the Buccaneers and
Jameis Winston one other team that I
thought about Peter give me your
thoughts on this how about the Tennessee
Titans if it doesn't work out with Ryan
Tannehill I've always thought that
Phillip Rivers made sense in Tennessee
post Mariota the problem is Tannehill
was so good last year that that thought
has kind of slid off the radar screen
but if they can't work something out
where they keep Tannehill does Phillip
Rivers make sense in Nashville
absolutely and I think first of all not
only would Mike Vrabel of them but
Rivers would be extremely motivated to
do this because I don't have a map in
front of me that's probably the closest
NFL franchise to his home it may be
other than Charlotte I don't know he's
from the very northern part of Alabama
and I should know my geography a little
bit better than that but those two
franchises I think especially because he
went to North Carolina State those two
franchises I think he'd be motivated to
go to one of those two because to him it
would feel like home well he plans to
play for up to two more years no more
than two more years we'll see who lines
up for Phillip Rivers in the coming days
weeks and months he won't be a free
agent Owen
till the middle of March he's not
available now but he will be available
when free agency begin
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports